상원의원이 도망쳤습니다.
2016년 5월 로널드 바토델라루사라는 필리핀 상원의원이
몇 달간의 잠적을 깨고 갑자기 상원에 나타났습니다.
그는 두테르테 전 대통령 시절 경찰청장을 지냈고
이른바 마약과의 전쟁을 현장에서 밀어붙였던 핵심 인물이었습니다.
국제형사재판소 ICC는 그를 반인도적 범죄 혐의로 수배하고 있었습니다.
그런데 그가 체포를 피하던 중 상원에 나타나서 결정적인 표를 던졌고
그 표는 상원의장을 두테르테 측 인물로 바꾸는 데 중요한 역할을 했습니다.
이후 체포 시도와 대치, 총성, 혼란이 이어졌고 그는 다시 사라졌습니다.
이 장면만 보면 마치 정치 스릴러의 한 장면 같습니다.
하지만 이건 단순히 도주극이 아닙니다.
필리핀 정치가 지금 어디에서 무너지고 있는지를 보여주는 압축된 장면입니다.
오늘 우리가 주목할 이야기는 바로 이 지점입니다.
왜 한 상원의원의 도주가 필리핀 전체 정치 위기에 상징이 되었을까?
그리고 왜 이 사건은 필리핀 내부 문제를 넘어 미국과 중국이 부딪히는 동남아 질서와도 연결될 수 있을까요?
겉으로 보면 지금 필리핀에서는 대통령과 부통령이 싸우고 있습니다.
마르코스 가문과 두테르테 가문이 싸우고 있죠.
하지만 더 깊이 들어가면 위기의 본질은 따로 있습니다.
필리핀의 위기는 민주주의가 선거만으로 지켜지지 않는다는 사실을 보여줍니다.
정당이 약하고 가문이 강하면 국가는 언제든 가족 간 전쟁의 무대가 됩니다.
필리핀 정치는 오랫동안 정치왕조의 영향력이 강했습니다.
각각의 정당이 어떤 철학을 가지고 있는가 보다 어떤 가문이 어떤 지역과 권력망을 장악하고 있는가가 더 중요하게 작동해 왔습니다.
그리고 지금 필리핀을 흔드는 두 이름이 바로 마르코스와 두테르테죠.
현재 대통령인 페르디난드 봉봉 마르코스 주니어는 필리핀의 전 독재자 페르디난드 마르코스의 아들입니다.
마르코스 가문은 필리핀 현대사에서 권력과 부패, 독재의 귀환이라는 복잡한 기억을 동시에 가진다.
반대편에는 두테르테 가문이 있습니다.
로드리고 두테르테는 2016년부터 2022년까지 필리핀 대통령을 지냈습니다.
그는 거친 언어, 강력한 법 집행, 그리고 수많은 사망자를 낳은 마약전쟁으로 세계적인 논란의 중심에 섰습니다.
그의 딸이 바로 현재 부통령인 사라 두테르테입니다.
흥미로운 점은 이 두 가문이 원래부터 적이 아니었다는 겁니다.
2022년 대선에서 두 가문은 손을 잡았습니다.
마르코스는 대통령 후보로,
사라 두테르테는 부통령 후보로 나섰죠.
결과는 당연히 압승이었습니다.
마르코스는 그래서 대통령이 되었고,
사라 두테르테는 부통령이 되었습니다.
겉으로 보면 필리핀의 두 거대한 정치 가문이 손을 잡으면서 강력한 안정정부가 탄생한 것처럼 보였습니다.
하지만 여기에는 처음부터 문제가 있었습니다.
이 동맹은 나라를 함께 운영하기 위한 약속이라 보다 선거를 이기기 위한 거래에 가까웠습니다.
선거에서는 같은 편일 수 있습니다.
하지만 통치에서는 권력이,
권력을 나눠야 합니다.
예산을 나눠야 하고,
인사를 나눠야 하고,
책임을 나눠야 합니다.
그리고 무엇보다 중요한 질문이 남습니다.
다음 대통령은 누가 될 것인가?
필리핀 대통령은 단임제입니다.
마르코스는 2028년에 다시 대통령에 출마할 수 없습니다.
그렇다면 다음 권력을 둘러싼 경쟁은 일찍 시작될 수밖에 없겠죠.
그 중심에 사라 두테르테가 있었습니다.
그녀는 2028년 대선의 유력한 후보로 거론되어 왔습니다.
여기서부터 동맹은 빠르게 흔들리기 시작합니다.
2024년 마르코스와 두테르테의 갈등은 공개적인 말싸움으로 번졌습니다.
두테르테 측은 마르코스가 마약을 한다는 식의 공격을 했고,
마르코스가 임기 제한을 바꾸려 한다는 의혹도 제기했습니다.
마르코스 측도 두테르테 가문을 점점 압박하기 시작하죠.
결정적인 분기점은 사라 두테르테가 내각에서 물러난 일이었습니다.
대통령직은 유지했지만 마르코스 정부 안에서 함께 일하는 자리는 내려놓았습니다.
대통령과 부통령이 같은 배를 탔지만 더 이상 같은 방향을 보지 않는다는 뜻이었습니다.
그리고 그 갈등은 곧 탄핵으로 이어졌습니다.
사라 두테르테는 자신이 살해될 경우 대통령과 영부인 하원 의장을 죽이라고 지시했다는 취지의 발언으로 큰 논란에 휩싸였습니다.
이후 하원은 그녀를 탄핵했습니다.
혐의에는 공급 유용, 설명되지 않는 재산, 대통령과 영부인 등에 대한 위협이 포함됐습니다.
사라 두테르테는 혐의를 부인했고, 탄핵은 정치적 보복이라고 주장했습니다.
여기서 중요한 것은 탄핵 그 자체라기보다 탄핵이 놓인 위치입니다.
탄핵은 법적 절차입니다.
하지만 동시에 정치적 절차이기도 하죠.
사라 두테르테가 유죄를 받으면 부통령직에서 물러날 수 있고 향후 공직 출마도 막힐 수 있습니다.
그렇게 되면 2018년 대선 구도는 완전히 달라지겠죠.
마르코스 진영 입장에서는 가장 강력한 경쟁자를 제거하는 효과가 생깁니다.
두테르테 진영 입장에서는 가문의 권력 복귀 가능성이 막히는 셈입니다.
그래서 이 싸움은 단순히 부통령이 잘못했는가의 싸움이 아닙니다.
물론 혐의가 있다면 조사해야 합니다.
공급 유용이 있었다면
책임을 밝혀야 하고
위협 발언이 있었다면 책임을 물어야겠죠.
마약 전쟁의 피해자가 있었다면
그 고통도 외면해서는 안 될 겁니다.
하지만 필리핀의 문제는 여기서 복잡해집니다.
법적 책임을 묻는 절차조차
어느 가문이 상원을 장악하느냐에 따라
운명이 달라질 수 있기 때문입니다.
필리핀에서 부통령 탄핵은 하원에서 시작되지만
최종 판단은 상원에서 이루어집니다.
상원 의원들이 재판관처럼 역할을 하고
유죄 판단에는 3분의 2 이상의 찬성이 필요합니다.
그런데
그 시점에
델라로사가 상원에 나타났고
상원 의장 교체에 힘을 보탰습니다.
새 상원 의장은
두테르테 가문과 매우 가까운 인물로 평가됩니다.
그리고 그는
사라 두테르테 탄핵 재판을 주재할 위치에 올라섰습니다.
이 장면이 중요한 이유가 여기에 있습니다.
상원은 원래 헌법 절차의 무대여야 합니다.
하지만 지금 필리핀에서 상원은
권력투쟁의 전장이 되었습니다.
하원은 탄핵을 밀어붙이고 상원은 재판을 통제하고
대법원은 절차를 따지고
국제형사재판소는
두테르테 시절의 책임을 묻습니다.
제도는 분명히 존재하고 있죠.
그런데 그 제도들이
시민을 위한 중립적 장치로 작동하기보다
정치 가문들이
서로를 공격하거나
보호하는 도구로 전락해 버린 겁니다.
여기에 ICC라는 국제 변수까지 붙습니다.
로드리고 두테르테 전 대통령은
재임 시절 마약과의 전쟁을 강하게 밀어붙였습니다.
그 과정에서
수많은 사람들이 사망했습니다.
두테르테 측은
범죄와 싸운 것이라고 주장했지만
인권단체들은
초법적 처형과 조직적 폭력을 문제 삼아 왔습니다.
ICC는 두테르테 전 대통령 뿐만 아니라
델라로사에게도 책임을 묻고 있습니다.
그러면서 필리핀의 국내 권력투쟁은
국제사법 문제와도 맞물리게 되었습니다.
그리고 이 싸움은
외교 노선과도 연결됩니다.
두테르테는
대통령 시절 중국과 비교적
가까운 관계를 추구했습니다.
반면 마르코스 주니어는
미국과의 안보 협력을 강화하고
남중국해 문제에서
중국에 더 강한 태도를 보여왔습니다.
남중국해는 단순한 바다가 아닙니다.
해상 교통로이고
자원분쟁지역으로
미국과 중국의 힘이 맞부딪히는 공간입니다.
필리핀은 그 한복판에 있습니다.
따라서 2018년에
누가 필리핀을 이끌게 되느냐는
필리핀만의 문제가 아닙니다.
미국의 인도태평양 전략
중국의 해양 팽창
일본과의 안보 협력
동남아 질서와도 연결이 됩니다.
결국 지금 필리핀 위기의 본질은
제도는 있는데 신뢰가 약합니다.
선거는 있는데 정당이 약합니다.
국가는 있는데 가문이 너무 강합니다.
그래서 정치적 동맹이 깨지면
국가 전체가 흔들리고 있습니다.
2022년 마르코스와 두테르테가 손을 잡았을 때
많은 사람들이
드디어 필리핀의 안정적인 정부가 들어섰다고 생각했습니다.
하지만 안정은
힘 있는 가문끼리
권력을 나눠 갖는다고 생기지 않습니다.
진짜 안정은
제도가 특정 가문보다 강할 때 생깁니다.
정당이 인물보다 강하고
법원이 권력보다 강하고
시민의 감시가
정치 혈통보다 강할 때 생깁니다.
필리핀은 지금 그 반대의 장면을 보여주고 있습니다.
상훈 의원이
도망쳤습니다.
부통령은 탄핵 재판을 앞두고 있습니다.
전직 대통령은
국제형사재판소의 피고가 되었습니다.
그리고 그 모든 사건 뒤에는
2028년 권력을 둘러싼
두 정치 가문의 싸움이 있습니다.
이 장면을
단순히 먼 나라의 혼란으로만 보면
우리는 중요한 질문을 놓치게 됩니다.
민주주의는
선거만으로 충분한가?
국민이 투표로 지도자를 뽑았다고 해서
그 정치가 곧 시민의 것이 되는 것인가?
필리핀의 위기는
우리에게 불편한 진실을 보여줍니다.
민주주의의
반대말은
언제나 군부 쿠데타나 독재만은 아닙니다.
국가의 제도가
시민보다 특정 세력의 사적인 이익을 위해 움직이기 시작할 때
민주주의는
조용히 사유화됩니다.
오늘도 영상 시청해 주셔서 감사합니다.